Well,
I will answer the question with the
caveat that I've been on the job all
four months now,
and so I'm trying to understand that at
greater depth and see how it needs to be
shaped going forward.
But the basics are these,
there are four national,
three national academies,
uh,
here in the US National Academy of
Science,
National Academy of Engineering,
and the Institute of Medicine,
uh,
collectively we operate something called
the National Research Council.
Now in a nutshell,
the academies are chartered by the US
Congress to be literally the advisors to
the nation in science,
engineering and medicine.
So sort of core activities of the
National Academy of Engineering are
threefold.
One is simply an honorific organization
through a,
a,
almost byzantine but very detailed
process.
We try to select and elect as,
as a membership,
the most accomplished engineers in the
country from both academia and industry
and,
and elsewhere.
So honorific,
uh,
then we also administer a number of
major prizes,
particularly the draper prize,
which is sort of the highest a prize
that the private sector gives for,
uh,
engineering,
accomplishment.
That's gone.
The people who invented the jet engine
in the world wide web and so forth,
and then the bulk of our work,
however,
is in producing reports on specific
topics generally requested by the
congress,
sometimes by the administration,
sometimes by ourselves on technological
issues facing the country,
either very specific or sometimes much
broader and try to provide that advice
to how we keep a sound,
a technological leadership in the US.
So day to day is really a lot like day
to day was as a university president if
you take away the students and you take
away the sometimes heavy emotional
pressures that one feels as a university
president.
So I'm delighted to say that I'm always
around bright people,
uh,
because we always have groups coming in
and out to do studies,
uh,
leaders from industry leaders from
university worrying about generally
large important,
uh,
problems and trying to help shepherd
that process along to get the right
people to do the right studies.
And then to help promulgate a,
uh,
what we find is sort of what constitutes
a,
the day to day a business that at the
Naa,
he and I have to tell you at least so
far,
I'm also traveling a lot.
I was on the road 36 days the last two
months,
giving speeches,
uh,
um,
helping to run meetings,
giving awards,
all these kinds of things.
So it's not a,
a,
a slow retirement,
a retirement job.
I accepted this honor because I feel
that the future of this nation,
and indeed the world is increasingly
dependent on having sound technological
leadership and strong science and
engineering and medicine undergirding
our public policy.
What our industries are doing.
And I'm particularly interested in the
opportunities to help people think about
what the evolving global context of all
this is and what our opportunities are,
particularly for the next generation of
young people.